freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video es ist mal wieder zeit es
sind ein paar neue in fenster produkte
rausgekommen ich glaube das erste video
in dem ich in fenster produkte getestet
habe es über ein jahr her und wir haben
fünf verschiedene produkte bzw
produktgruppen rausgesucht die wir heute
testen wir haben hier auf der linken
seite pamela wriedt cluster hier drüben
haben wir lukas podolski chips werden
das thema vielleicht schon mal arbeitet
auch chips rausgebracht hey moritz
kaugummis das ist nicht meine die musste
ich mir besorgen wir sind deshalb schon
geöffnet ich habe aber noch nicht
probiert nova love me und hier drüben
ganz ganz viel dirty von shirin david
und hier ist der erste kandidat die
pamela reif ich hoffe ich sag's richtig
nett cluster erstmal fünf das schon hart
alter klar nüsse auch teuer man kennt
das wenn man macadamia kauf oder so was
kann schon mal teuer sein aber das sind
90 gramm finde ich schon es ist schon
viel hoch wenn man sich danach dann auch
noch gut fühlst dann ist es natürlich
wieder was anderes ansonsten sieht auf
jeden fall von wem es kommt sieht man
auf jeden fall aber wir probieren das
ganze mal organisch entwickeln hifi
brocade über guten free to play brings
cateringservice
probieren wir einfach erster geschmack
peanut butter schokolade
also dunkel entschied wazv genau was man
erwartet ein bisschen knuspriger
wirklich nicht sehr süß also man sieht
dass ich denke so ein mist tom kennst du
diesen erdnuss riegel wo so karamell so
dabei ist kennst du das der tag lebt
aber mehr die zähne und so 100 prozent
ist das hier viel besser für dich ob es
jetzt so krass gesucht freiheit ist ja
auch nicht krank ecocarrier cacau
ich denke mir besser aber dass die
anderen das ding ist ich bewerte das
jetzt auf der snec sgraja und snacks
kamen gesund sein muss das für mich aber
nicht sein sonst und dafür dadurch dass
du halt so was aufhält dem es auch wenig
zucker und so klar lässt so ein bisschen
geschmack auf der spur sondern ich mag
auf der strecke mit dem so rein vom
geschmack her 6 von 10 6 von 10 pa
zement klingt schon mal greifen nicht
es ist gar nicht so krass wird genauso
wie die peanuts schoko dinge auch nur 6
das ist halt so nichts was sich so
begeistert so vom geschmack her für die
zielgruppe ist das safe perfekt für mich
geht aber ist es relativ teuer deshalb
600 und ich haben uns gerade gefragt
welches produkt findet ihr würde zu mir
passen ich habe wirklich keine ahnung
was das ihr jetzt antworten würde ich
habe auch akut nichts geplant aber es
interessiert mich trotzdem welches
produkt passt zu mir und weiter geht's
wir wechseln die straßenseite und wir
sind jetzt bei den snacks angekommen die
nicht darauf bedacht sind gesund zu sein
und zwar mangal lukas podolski chips so
einmalig schöner geschmack und einmal
mit tzatziki geschmack tsatsiki probiert
als erstes können mir vorstellen das
geht so bis in die richtung von so sauer
green ships ohne aber dünner geschmack
wenn ich komplett gespannt ob
das richtig nach 40 geht es nicht auch
schon so auf der nabu das bricht aber
gut muss ich sagen so wenn wir uns das
ganze mal anschauen rops hatten wir auch
schon in der intensität produktreihe ich
habe so ein bisschen was man sieht aber
da ist auf jeden fall ordentlich gewürz
dran und so die tüte sowie jedes foto
ist halbleer ist ja so viel luft drin
damit die nicht kaputt gehen und sondern
beim transport ticket also vom geruch
her noch nie gegessen
okay man kommt sehr in die richtung von
suzuki schmeckt er nach so dass die
bühne also weißt du also schmeckt schon
sehr lecker muss ich sagen es hat von
der textur her sind das perfekte chips
also die müssen nicht dicker sein so die
müssen nicht dünner sein so wir sind
geil so ich finde auch den geschmack
eigentlich ehrlich gut muss ich sagen
ich würde den glaube ich das einfach so
aus dem bauch heraus was sagst du
achteinhalb oder 97 innerhalb gibst du
898 ein halbes pferd jetzt bin ich
gespannt döner chips wie ich das jetzt
erst mal
vor allem schmecken und zeichen also
sieht schon mal ganz anders aus wenn
noch mal in diesem jahr die sind sogar
ein bisschen dünner wenn ich mich nicht
irre probieren wir original lukas
podolski döner chips
der schmeckt nur noch dünner ich bin
büchel probier mal wird das schmeckt für
mich wie ganz klassische ungarisch also
ich bin erstmal die hier viel stärker
weil die sind viel charakteristischer so
aber wenn bastian acht und halb ist
kummer als chips für sich wenn ich nicht
wüsste was ist greift in der bol es dass
durchsage stabil sind nämlich genauso
texturen eis alles wie die beiden
anderen aber wenn ich döner erwartet
dass das ein bisschen ein bisschen
enttäuschend als normale chips würde ich
denen so eine siebeneinhalb geben wenn
man döner erwartet entsprechend weniger
keine ich will mich fest ich will ja
auch nicht trocken premium dünner chips
die prämie sind aber nicht nachdenken
dirty von shirin david ich muss ehrlich
sagen bildhübsch also die einzigen die
ich nicht so schön finden sind die
kleinen hier alle anderen sind
designmäßig durch keller also finde ich
richtig gefällt mir persönlich richtig
richtig gut auch mit diesen decken hier
oben drauf es hat ja mit den drei sorten
hier angefangen also normale ice t dann
kamen die mit alkohol und sprudelt und
dann kam die zero die sind relativ
frisch ich habe einen von den drei mal
getestet aber das verlangen her deshalb
legen wir los
es riecht gerade wie man sich so einen
amerikanischen süßigkeiten laden
vorstellt oder es riecht wirklich so es
riecht bisschen künstlich vielleicht
aber es riecht sehr sehr lecker also ich
persönlich wäre das sehr so befand
upgrade so ich liebe so krasse getränke
weil wenn man so was trinken dann
richtig so dass meine meinung dann haben
wir jetzt hier den ersten kandidaten
bass die blume mit basti blueberry
sowohl
tatsächlich ich habe viel gehört weniger
süß ich gedacht habe nicht zu süß
stabiler blaubär geschmack acht von zehn
dirty candy shop
das riecht nicht so ich meine ja gerade
hier riecht's nach nach süßigkeiten
laden das riecht nur nach zuckerwatte so
das ist auf jeden fall relativ süß aber
also ich würde mir nicht holen und den
blauen würde ich mir aber holen der hier
kein verdienst für holen würde aber auch
nicht schlecht sieben von zehn nächster
flavour match
ich habe lange nicht einfach mir so ein
ice t gold für mich schmeckt was nach
einem absoluten standard ice t deshalb
macht er nichts besser nichts besser
nicht schlechter dirty ist ja schon für
eistee so auch literpreis ein bisschen
teurer deshalb auch sieben von zehn ich
habe getrunken jetzt trinke ich webpage
zero zum wohl
zero ist süßer als normal es ist
unnormal süß das hat auch weniger
geschmack das schmeckt weniger nach nach
pietsch als der andere das ding ist kann
man vergleich jetzt halt ein
zuckerhaltiges getränk mit einem zero
getränk ist auch ein bisschen um ferne
das heißt es erst mal in meinem leben
dass die ice c zero trinke so deshalb
kein staat also ich würde genauso wie
mit dem anderen pietsch gehen meist klar
dass du ein bisschen geschmack verliert
so wenn du es halt nach empfindest somit
süßmittel dafür stabil dass sieben von
zehn und dirty zero lemon ich bin schon
mal nicht team zitroneneis ich bin eher
team für sich es riecht aber geil nach
zitronen und riecht ein bisschen an
katar mäßig weißt du the man from heaven
einen halben punkt weniger geil als
erster patch aus prinzip sechseinhalb
prozent jetzt kommen wir zu den
hässlichen micro und endlich wir haben's
sparkling candy shop
sparkling tea mango
ich muss aber knapp daneben alter ist
doch viel süßer wenn ich mir jetzt ein
alkoholisches getränk wollen würde ich
mir niemals das hier holen das ist aber
also ich bin auch dafür nicht die
zielgruppe ich rede jetzt von meiner
werte ich bin mir sicher mit 16 hätte
ich das übelste gefunden hätte ich dem
vielleicht achten hype gegeben aber als
ich jetzt gebe ich den fünfeinhalb und
den hier gebe ich 6 alles in allem
nichtsdestotrotz richtig stabile
produkte also wirklich ne aber die sind
nicht für mich abzulesen als nächstes
haben wir die motti von novell an allah
falls noch mal anders editions
cheesecake solltet karl may hat relativ
wenig mit den klassischen japanischen
moschee zu tun die also reiskuchen sind
kein bisschen zäh bisschen klebrig innen
drin missionen passte gefüllt meistens
kein motto wer also gerade die
klassischen mag ich sehr gerne ich hab
schon 14 mal so bei swatch gegessen
mochte ich nie so gerne wie die
klassischen sorgt man sich fünf minuten
anschauen lassen das haben wir gemacht
dieser anblick hier bietet sich uns an
direkt rein oder
also konsistenz sehr geil dass diese
füllung so diesen flüssige trading ist
ultra geschmack cheesecake sold on point
es ist 11 cheesecake sollte man hat auch
trotzdem so diesen brocken zu essen also
macht alles richtig
[Gelächter]
ob das schon reicht ich sage ehrlich das
alles schmeckt gut dass mal was neues
bestimmt geil jetzt nach dem ganzen
system installieren sagt müsse man sich
etwas zum fressen preschen und wieder zu
bekommen
letztes produkt letzte produkte hey hey
mit hey kaugummis sie sind schon
geöffnet denn denkste zugeschickt
bekommen und ein paar davon gekostet da
sind alle drei geschmacksrichtungen
minze tropical wassermelone also
eigentlich klassische kaugummi
geschmäcker den klassiker minz macht zum
abschluss weil da kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass so viel passiert sodass
sind so dragees also so überzogene
kaugummis sondern ich probier erstmal
tropical
also gehen wir erstmal stück also dieser
über zuges relativ dick das heißt man
erst mal so ein quatsch
damit ist aber relativ leicht zu kommen
helga wassermelone
problemlos letzte
also schmeckt wirklich 15 was soll ich
sagen also ganz ehrlich das sind richtig
scheiße kaugummis machen alles richtig
das ist so ein neues addon dass sie so
ein bisschen kräftiger sind so zum
anfang dementsprechend es ist jetzt
nichts was mich so krass vom hocker haut
deshalb weil es aber trotzdem richtig
gut ist ich bin so zwischen 8 und
achteinhalb einfach so durch die bank
weil jedes ist genau gleich gut in allem
was macht ich weiß nicht heute war ein
bisschen kritischer eingestellt als
sonst aber alle sagen trotzdem coole
produkte und auch eigentlich allesamt
besser als der durchschnitt sondern in
der eigenen produktkategorie an alle die
im video waren macht weiter so sehr sehr
geil nicht alles war für mich aber ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns im nächsten
video wieder bis dahin macht's gut